greetings everyone welcome to simply
learn my name's Rob Sanders and I am
going to talk about how to rank YouTube
videos today so it's simply learn we
take our videos on YouTube very
seriously
meaning that when we create videos we
want people to see them because we know
we make good videos and we know we have
good content and we know that our
audience is going to enjoy it and so we
want our audience to see the videos that
we're creating and so we're going to
give you some tips and tricks and
methodology and ideas on how to get your
videos to rank on YouTube so at simply
learn if I go to YouTube and I just type
in machine learning you can see we're
right here is the first organic video on
YouTube for machine learning if I jump
over to Google and I type in machine
learning basics you can see we're number
we're number 1 for machine learning
basics under videos if I click on all
we're also ranked here as well under the
video section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number 1 for that if
I look at another keyword data science
interview questions ok we're ranked
number 2 for that so we're ranking for a
lot of videos and why are we ranking for
a lot of different content and videos on
Google search and on YouTube well we've
put a lot of work in behind the scenes
of creating the video and that's what we
want to show you so part of that has a
lot to do with you know how our audience
engages and sees our video so for
example we're looking at of the machine
learning basics video here and we could
see that it has over 220 1000
subscribers for this video 234 thousand
views we've had over 2,000 people like
the video and we have had over 270 plus
comment on the video so when we get our
videos to rank then we can see there's a
lot of engagement and so that's the
whole idea is when you do a video and
you want to show up on YouTube you want
people to enjoy you want people to
you want people to like it you want
people to comment on it and that's part
of the whole ecosystem of YouTube it's
you know we're gonna show you behind the
scenes of what it takes to get your
videos to rank and then we're gonna show
you some of the metrics involved with
some of these videos to help you stay
ranking so without further ado let's go
into how to get your videos to rank on
YouTube so we're going to talk about
keyword research for YouTube we're gonna
talk about some ways to create high
quality videos so the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're gonna get
into how to promote your content and
then we're gonna just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to set our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the webpages on our
website so if we have somebody who stays
YouTube is the world's second most well
well-known engine well it is because
it's right behind Google it's not a
search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a certian it'd
probably be second right behind Google
so YouTube is pretty popular majority
people use YouTube search every day to
watch videos on a number of different
topics so they can find these videos in
Google but because YouTube's so powerful
and so popular people go directly right
into YouTube for their searches and so
the whole idea behind YouTube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on YouTube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on YouTube just like for those of
you who watched any of the SEO videos we
produced it simply learned you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your webpages to rank
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your webpages so we're gonna go into a
few things to do here to find the right
keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other and factors involved
in Google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
first thing is search suggests so
YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I choose you know machine
learning tutorial I'm gonna see a video
about machine learning tutorial so here
you can see simply learns rank number
one for machine learning tutorial but
there are other videos that show up in
my search result so we want to be able
to use the search suggestion box in the
search box field so when we're typing in
something you know YouTube just like on
Google is gonna give us those
suggestions so if we're focusing a video
on machine learning then you know we
have some ideas of some other keywords
that we could center around because
these are our popular keywords these are
keywords that people are using to search
on YouTube so that's one suggestion
looking at competitors is another
suggestion so we could search for
keywords used by our competitors in
their video title and description so let
me talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors youtube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and they
and what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're gonna choose a video
and then what you're gonna do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title description and then once you do
that you're gonna have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type and simply
learn here's our channel page just by
clicking on simply learn and click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all I've ever wonder if there's
an easier way go back so here I can see
all the videos sort by most popular once
you do that then I could choose a video
this is the most popular video right now
for simply learn if I click on that
video it's automatically gonna start
playing but what I could do is simply
just look at you know the content
description so just by clicking show
more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is to look at the tags associated with
the particular video and so what you
want to do is you want to look at the
HTML and so that means looking at the
page source so just like web pages what
YouTube does is they look at meta tags
so if you call from SEO in order to get
your pages to rank you need to have a
title tag in a meta tag description so
videos are no different what we're doing
for YouTube is aligning certain keywords
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page source you're gonna see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video let's just say this video here
Facebook's add tutorial I'm gonna pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're lining with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if we use that YouTube
autocomplete it's gonna give you those
ideas this was popular keywords so if
they're related align those keywords
with the video so here you can see
Facebook marketing Facebook Ads strategy
Facebook ads for beginners so forth and
so on so there's a lot of keywords we've
aligned here with that particular video
and again all you need to do is to look
at the page source so right clicking
view page source to a control F for
keywords and you'll be able to see the
keywords aligned so you could do that
for your competitors videos as well so
you can see what keywords your
competitors using for a video that's
most popular for their channel and is
also ranking on YouTube and on Google so
using the autocomplete gives you those
keyword ideas looking at your
competitors videos also gives you some
other ideas for keywords that you can
align with a video that's relevant that
you want to rank for so let's look at
some other ideas here so you can install
plugins and there are plenty of plugins
available on the chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples or vid IQ and two
buddy
those are extensions that work in Chrome
and what they do is they give you the
exact tags that a particular video is
using so for example if I go back here
and I look at a video on YouTube let's
just say the machine learning basics
video I have vid IQ installed on my
Chrome browser so just by clicking on
that vid IQ is going to give me a lot of
information about that video you're just
gonna give me an overview of their
particular metrics they're gonna give me
some other information associated with
Facebook some engagement metrics really
what I'm interested in is those keywords
so if I scroll down a bit here I can see
the video tags associated with the
machine learning basics video so vid IQ
is telling me as these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where
they rank so for machine learning basics
this particular video ranks number one
if I go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's ranked number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular videos so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitor's video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're gonna give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure
we choose keywords with high search
volume they're going to drive more
traffic to your video however we want to
balance it out with keywords that have
low difficulty and are easier to rank
for so you don't want to choose
something very broad that's just gonna
be very difficult to rank for and of
course we always want to go with
relevancy so for talking about machine
learning basics then we want to choose
keywords associated with that and that's
where that autocomplete comes in handy
because what Google's going to do and
YouTube's going to do is give us
keywords that are very closely related
to the video that we're trying to
optimize for and so we have a number of
different keywords at our disposal that
are relevant that we can look to see if
they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
our high volume low competition are
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the content
is about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine-learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning basics
video so well-chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning basics
video if I just type in machine learning
basics I'll be able to pull it out and
so here it is I click on it I'm gonna go
to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know she was known from do
pop is well aligned because it's in the
title it's in the copy and it's aligned
as a keyword tag with the video so we
know that that keyword has good volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction I mean machine learning
primary keyword is machine learning
basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords what is
machine learning because somebody who
doesn't own machine
is probably going to type in that
keyword and then introduction of machine
learning is a good secondary keyword
because it's explaining the basics of
what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning and introduction to machine
learning so that's the whole idea behind
choosing keywords you want that keyword
that really is going to define the
content and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video results page
so what I mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on Google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you could see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on Google search you can always
just when you do a search what Google is
going to do is also put in the videos
here on part as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we'll ranked number
one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko Google ranks videos with
keywords like how-to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google is doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how-to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal
to Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're gonna get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how-to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you write so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how-to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of a
hundred characters so we really have to
pick and choose really wisely so if we
look at the video that we were focusing
on a couple of minutes ago so machine
learning basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so takes into
account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords in the title and it
also includes that really the key term
it really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title as to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
high click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video title is what's
going to show up in search so if I go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
signs for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data signs
in five minutes so that was purposely
done so that hey I don't have time to
watch a video I only
have a couple minutes data science in
five minutes okay great I'm gonna click
on the video and now I have an
opportunity to watch something and learn
something under five minutes so choosing
the right words and your video title is
going to help you get that click-through
rate up remember click the rate please
clicks / impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up in
the search results on YouTube or Google
so we want to keep our click-through
rate high and in order to do that we
want to be able to write some really
good title tags for our video so use
catchy words like a number or how-to or
what is because that's gonna resonate
with people when they're searching now
for the description what we want to do
is we want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so let go back to my
video here machine learning basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5,000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5,000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that key word that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with key words at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your key words naturally and
then include hashtags in your scription
to help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social
it just signals to the end user hey this
is what the video is all about and if I
go ahead and type in that keyword then
it's our video has a better chance
because it's a line with that hashtag
and then there's target keywords and LSI
keywords latent semantic indexing
keywords we want to be able to use those
keywords as target keywords with our
video so if you recall the example I
gave a few minutes ago we used the
Facebook Ads tutorial as our example
here I can see all the target keywords
associated with that particular video so
don't be afraid to use those LSI related
keywords meaning keywords that are
related to the content use them as
target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to us YouTube
itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube let's turn our
attention to creating high quality
videos and some of the best practices
around that so along with everything we
mentioned about choosing the right
keywords we always need to keep in mind
that the videos we create need to be of
high quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords is a primary
factor in ranking so in order to have
keywords we need to have cons
and in order to rank we need to have no
good content so let's talk a little bit
about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or relevant to the topic it
won't rank so that's just common sense
so you need to create content that's
aligned with the topic obviously and
then that way you have keywords that are
aligned with the content so but if you
have content really isn't aligned with
the topic then you're not gonna rank no
matter how much you've optimized that
video so just keep that in mind
so there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good a high quality
video we created we want to look at
audience retention and user engagement
so audience retention is simply the
percentage length of your video that the
audience has watched it's the percentage
your audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention is important for
people who want their videos to rank
high so if you want a rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but gotta keep
in mind content so content is related to
audience retention and user engagement
so audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience is watched and for example they
can be both absolute in minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so yours engagement
of viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it's subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean be
longer videos so what's the reason for
longer videos let's just suppose we have
two videos one shorter and lengthen went
longer in lame first videos fifteen
minutes long the second video is seven
minutes long so on average if viewers
watch about 40% of both videos then
video X which is 15 minutes long will
have more than twice the watch time of
the video that's seven minutes long so
remember duration we want you know
people to watch our videos longer so if
the video is longer in length if it's
40% then it's gonna have a longer
audience engagement audience retention
so that's one of the reasons you know
from a metric standpoint
so even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to different so
we want to take into account longer
videos for primarily that reason is
because you know it gives a not an end
user an opportunity to watch the video
longer and then it's going to help us
rank our videos longer so when we talk
about watch time so if one video has
higher watch time in the other watch
time is just the number of views times
the average view duration so another tip
is we want to plan our video script so
we want to keep the content organized my
recommendation is you know create an
outline first and once you create an
outline of how the video is gonna flow
then start populating with content and
so to me that's how you can keep the
flow organized okay is really with an
outline starting out with a no majalis
no videos are no different than say a
presentation if you've done a PowerPoint
presentation you always want to start
out doing an outline then we want to
upload a high resolution videos high
resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know a small resolution
like say you know 400 by 400 resolution
or something you know something really
small we want to create something a very
high res so according to back or link
goats more than 50% of videos on the
first page of YouTube or high def
so high-definition videos of higher
quality are going to be shown on the
first page of YouTube more often than
not so high resolution videos organizing
the content publishing longer videos are
examples of creating high quality videos
we also want to make sure that content
is relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning then when they watch the video
they're expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day view
users going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to create high
quality videos so we want to be able to
you know use examples to clarify our
content so you know don't be afraid to
go into another screen like I am I want
to I'm talking about videos jump into
the machine learning basics video which
I've done throughout this session I can
simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning basics well the title is online
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about and we're aligning the
expectations so not only that I'm
showing you example within the video
itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you
to use good images in your video so use
public domain sites that are available
to you like Shutterstock or a flat icon
I mean there are plenty of those sites
out there so feel free to use any one of
those sites to use high quality images
in your video give more information to
your audience giving maximum relevant
information can help gain more views and
so when we talk about more information
again it goes back to you know examples
use there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all five
thousand characters at your disposal
imagery we want to build up as much
information as you can in the video
itself to keep the end user the viewer
engaged we also want to create original
content so always create original
content you can certainly get ideas from
you too if you want to create a video
about machine learning see what else has
already been done do searches on YouTube
itself but you know when you're gonna
create a video yeah you can create
another video about what is machine
learning but just make sure it has your
own take on it you're the subject-matter
expert when creating the video creating
with your own original content have high
audio quality and video effects so just
like you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality
meaning no background noise no
distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say
or what the viewers trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts it's just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that car
and help your video rank so to me that's
a key component to creating a good video
is having the necessary content that go
along with the video that outline I
referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
content outline so what topics are you
gonna cover in the video that's why you
need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video they focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's gonna click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out
altogether so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in YouTube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage we'll show you an example of
what that looks like so here if we go to
the machine learning basics video we can
look at the audience retention report
and this is since it's been uploaded the
lifetime audience retention so here we
can see a nice graph the percentage of
people who viewed it and how long they
viewed it so in percentage so here for
example I can see you know 43 44 % watch
the video for at least two minutes here
I can see 28.6% Watership for six
minutes applause so that's the audience
retention it gives us an idea in terms
of percentage how many people or
percentage of people watch the video at
what length so that's audience retention
so we want to keep that number high at
the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organize content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all best practices
to keep the viewer engaged and then we
want to add resources from well-known
sites so throughout this video we've
used backlinko
there are other sources we've used so if
you have a source go ahead and put it in
your video to add credibility and then
we want to use cards to your videos so
this cards is basically a feature that
recommends relevant videos to your
audience so in addition to machine
learning basics there could be other
videos about machine learning that we
can recommend or you too can recommend
to the audience to set up end screens
you want to make sure that with end
screens you can use relevant videos to
your audience towards the end of your
video so you can recommend relevant
videos towards the end of your video you
can also create playlists so this is a
feature that keeps your audience engaged
with relevant content by autoplay in the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's gonna go from one video to another
pattern interrupts keep the audience
engaged so basically it allows your
audience to stay within one video
without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42% 43%
watched it on an average of 3 minutes
and 21 seconds so to me that's pretty
good of course we always want a hundred
percent of the video the video is seven
minutes long if almost half of our
audience saw over half of the video then
I would say that's pretty good people
were engaged so audience retention just
is a good report to start looking at to
help you understand how engaging is my
video and if your video is not engaging
you know you can always go back and edit
it or fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for
all videos and top-performing videos
listed by all time we can look at that
information as well in addition we can
look at demographics so we can get an
overview of the age gender and location
and we can look at playback locations
report and what the playback locations
report does is it helps us determine the
platform's where our videos are being
streamed from within YouTube look at the
traffic sources where did the viewers
come from devices did they look on
mobile or tablet and so there's any
doubts you know if you have any
questions please drop a comment below
but especially if you have any doubts on
the metrics so if we go back into
YouTube we can look in analytics and if
we're looking at a links we can see more
and then this is gonna show us
everything we need to see from device
type so if I click on more I can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video was watched it was on a
watch page or a channel page I can see
the traffic sources I could see the
gender and age so if I click on the
viewer age report I can see the
percentage of views by age so I can get
a lot of information about my video and
how its performed who's watched it what
they've done with it
where they come from all the information
they need to know so it's all within
YouTube analytics so again if you have
any questions about that
you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high-quality aligned with your keywords
you're gonna be able to view the metrics
by looking at YouTube analytics so let's
talk about the importance of user
engagement so engagement is as we
mentioned important because basically we
can't rank without engagement our videos
won't rank unless we have engagement so
that's why it's important so engagement
is somebody liking the video commenting
sharing it or subscribing each one of
these is important to ranking so yes you
need to line keywords yes you need to
have high quality content so when you do
both of those and you upload your video
up to the viewer and so the hard work
that you put out for the video is
hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to word stream if your
content is entertaining then over
three-quarters of the users are going to
share it so that's part of keeping users
engaged is keeping an entertaining is
part of getting a high quality video so
remember online high quality video when
we say entertaining the audio portion
has a lot to do with that examples has a
lot to do of that quality of the video
itself has a lot to do with it so a lot
of components so all those components on
a high quality video are going to lead
to engagement parts of what you could do
in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that
also helped you get some more comments
so according to backlink ooo video
comments help and rank in your video
higher so just as I mentioned the last
segment about YouTube analytics and all
the different reports available in
YouTube if you have questions than those
just go ahead and add a comment so
that's a way to entice your users or
your viewers to add comments is if they
have questions because you know with
videos you're not gonna make able to
cover every detail or every minut detail
about a particular topic you can only
cover in some cases the topic at a high
level so users are gonna have comments
or questions naturally and so the
comments section is a good way to remind
viewers hey if you have a question or
comment go ahead and put it in the
comments section because that will lend
to engagement as well so we want to add
sources from high quality websites
that'll help with engagement can use
humor in your video we want to be able
to basically you'll make it human based
we don't want to be robots so we want to
be able to
sound like you know we know we're
talking about at the same time talk to
the viewer not necessarily at the viewer
for looking the other way and just going
through the motions so adding humor
adding personality never hurts at the
end of the day we are all human adding
that clear call-to-action at the end of
the video will also lead to engagement
so if we win the video with hey leave
your comments on this video or hey feel
free to share this video with colleagues
who are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comment section
two more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you know
you're gonna start feeling really good
and what is that gonna do okay that feel
good is gonna lead to confidence which
in turn is gonna probably lead to more
videos and that's exactly what we do
it's simply learn we're in the education
business but we're in it to not only
educate but making sure that our videos
are shown to as many people as possible
so that we can educate as many people as
possible so it's all it's contagious so
getting ranked feels good and then once
you get ranked then you know you
probably have good engagement let's talk
about how to promote your content so
once you've done all the hard work
getting your video done high quality
content optimized with keywords and then
publish to YouTube we want to let
everybody in the world know about it
right so we want to promote it done all
the work we want to promote it now so is
it necessary to promote it I would say
yes because once your video is published
you want to reach out you want to reach
out to your audience
necessarily on YouTube but on different
platforms so if you're active on
Facebook or Twitter that's an
opportunity for you to post or tweet
something about the new video so when we
say different platforms I am talking
about you know social media platforms so
it depends on what you're active on so
if you're active on Facebook yeah go
ahead and post something you're active
on Twitter go ahead and tweet something
it could be you know on LinkedIn group
if you're part of a LinkedIn group about
you know machine learning then go ahead
and post something to that group to
promote the video so that's gonna help
drive traffic to the video and then help
with engagement so we want to engage
with our audience on those social media
sites so it really depends on what
you're active on so if you have a large
following on Twitter then go ahead and
you know share that YouTube video link
on Twitter with the tweet that's going
to drive traffic from Twitter to YouTube
remember you know you're gonna be able
to the audience engagement or retention
by getting people to watch the video so
you're gonna be able to see right away
by promoting the video and driving
traffic to the video how engaging it is
remember the more people you have watch
the video the more engaging it becomes
the better it's gonna rain so it's an
ecosystem and promoting your content as
part of that ecosystem so it all starts
with social media if you're active on
whatever platform that is go ahead and
promote it so you can also look at you
know content based social media sites or
social media content based platforms
like Reddit or Flickr for example so you
can participate in a forum discussion on
reddit so in this example here it's
about machine learning so we want to be
able to post something about machine
learning with the link to our video so
we can also go to content based sites
that are Q&A related like Korra
for example core is a really good site
where you know if you go there post
information about machine learning or
the basics of machine learning with the
link back to the video it's gonna help
because not only is it going to drive
traffic but it's gonna signal to Google
a lot of traffic coming from Korra this
is gonna bode well for this video
in terms of ranking so here's an example
you know if you find a question that you
can post on Korra then you're gonna get
people to click on your video and
respond accordingly on Korra or you can
act as the person responding to a
question that's already there so
somebody already asked a question about
what is machine learning
you can respond with your video as the
answer so you can just simply embed your
video url as part of your answer
that'll help drive traffic so you can
also create your own blog and embed your
videos so in the case of machine
learning here we have an example machine
learning what is it why it matters so
this goes nicely with the video so here
you can see the person the author of
this blog went ahead and embedded the
relevant video in the blog post so they
play off one another nicely you can also
opt in for influencer marking meaning
hey you can reach out to somebody in
this example here you know Katy nuggets
posted information about machine
learning so in this case why choose
machine learning as a career well they
get information and then what do they do
they went ahead and embedded the video
about machine learning basics and so
working with you know influencers in a
particular category or topic will help
drive traffic to the video you can also
create a YouTube playlist so playlists
tend to rank high on YouTube searches so
if you find yourself doing a lot of
videos well go ahead and you know go to
your channel and simply and your channel
you can go ahead and create playlists so
when you create playlists basically what
you're doing is you're organizing the
content into different playlists no
different than say the music you have
set up on your you know your iPhone or I
or or iPod whatever it is you're using
so you're just creating different videos
in a particular category in it YouTube
likes it it's organized it's gonna help
you get your videos found quicker and
easier on YouTube itself by putting your
videos in a playlist so here you can see
we have entire playlist on machine
learning training technologies cloud
computing Big Data digital marketing
project management's a lot of different
playlists very organized if somebody
goes to the channel they're gonna be
able to go to the playlist that's
interesting to them and see all the
videos there so it allows not only the
end-user to find what they're looking
for but it's good for YouTube because
YouTube likes those playlists so we want
to engage our audience by posting your
video link on a community page so you
could do that within YouTube and you can
prefer to link your YouTube channel in
your email so you can also do that so
for example if I go back to YouTube and
I'm looking at a YouTube video you know
I can always click share so here I'm
gonna get a particular URL that's
associated with a video and I can just
embed that so I can embed the whole
thing in my email I can embed it on a
web page or a blog post so just by
clicking share I can also immediately
share it on to social media platforms
that we mentioned Facebook LinkedIn
reddit okay tumblr so there's a lot of
ways to embed the video not just that a
blog post or influencer or blog post but
on our email and on social media as well
so here's an example of what we can do
with the YouTube discussion so we can
also bookmark the video on a popular
bookmarking site you know like stumbled
upon or reddit or you know there's lots
of other ones out there so there's
plenty of sites that you'll be able to
go to and bookmark that content so that
people can find it and you can always
opt for backlinks so that means that
hey if there's a blogger out there that
blogs about machine learning you can
always you know ask that blogger to
Freight a link back to the video and you
could reciprocate do the same thing so
that helps increase the authority of the
video so a lot of things you could do to
promote your video so let's do a quick
review on everything we talked about in
terms of ranking your video on YouTube
it all starts with the keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords well
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords what we can use the
autocomplete on YouTube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use bid IQ or tube buddy
or any of these extensions in chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video remember
we want to have a primary keyword that's
aligned with the content then we want to
choose LSI keywords as our secondary
keyword or keywords that are related to
the primary keyword so we want to create
high retention videos meaning that first
15 seconds of the most important but
throughout the video we want to use
examples we want to keep it interacting
by adding quizzes imagery good audio
good video quality so we want to focus
on the user experience and we also want
to optimize our video content what does
that mean
well those keywords that we chose we
want to use them in the title we want to
use them in the description we want to
use them as hashtags we want to use them
and tag them with the video themselves
so we can add keywords to our meta tag
okay we don't want to overdo it but we
want to add a handful of keywords that
is are associated with the video so we
want to be able to write eye catchy
video titles and descriptions so
remember use some of those key phrases
like a number or a question like what is
machine learning so we want to use
relevant meta tags for the videos
then we want to use popular YouTube tags
so we want to be able to tag our videos
appropriately to watch the length of
your meta tags so there are lengths
involved
remember keywords at the beginning of
the title target keywords in the title
description and tags we want to use
interesting thumbnails to increase our
click-through rate ensure that
thumbnails are relevant meaning when I
say thumbnails I mean the actual title
tag itself or the meta description we
want to use high-res videos we want to
create you know videos with good high
audio quality don't be afraid to put in
video effects like some animation don't
be afraid to use examples and then you
know obviously look at the draft of the
video before you publish it so does your
video follow an outline is it organized
so these are all the things to take into
account and there's there's plenty more
you can do you know you remember once
you create and optimize that video you
want to promote it you want to make sure
that you're sharing it on social media
you create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlist and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked so again
some key takeaways here use the keyword
research available to you on YouTube you
want to basically you know watch your
descriptions you want to be able to
align your keywords with your title and
meta tag description want to be able to
promote your content on social media on
social bookmarking though and I can't
stress enough create a high quality
video first 15 seconds are important but
you're gonna know if you have good
quality video because every video has
analytics
Shadid with it so we want to keep in
mind the engagement so just by looking
at the video itself so here I can see
this blockchain in seven minutes
it was just posted just yesterday 227 so
basically if already 42 likes 33
comments 378 views so these are all
engagement related metrics so you'll be
able to just look at the front of any
video and see how well it's performing
from an engagement standpoint so the
better the engagement the better of a
chance you have to rank thank you for
watching this video about how to rank
your YouTube videos if you have more
information visit simply learn comm or
right below the video go ahead and add a
comment
we'll be sure to respond accordingly and
quickly thank you very much and look
forward to seeing you on future videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here